Guten Tag.
Hatte ich jetzt mein Name?
Ich bin der Diensthabende auf dieser Station
und würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschäft führen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen,
bitte jederzeit können Sie mir jede Zeit stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Gerne.
Darf ich Ihren Namen erfahren?
Mein Name ist Schmidt, Paul Schmidt.
Schmidt, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Vornamen bestabeln?
Mein Vorname ist P wie Paul, A wie Anton, U wie Ulrich, L wie Ludwig
und mein Nachname ist Schmidt, S, C, H, M wie Martha, I wie Ida, D wie Dora, T wie Theodora.
Okay, Herr Paul, wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt. Ich bin geboren am 14. März 1968.
Herr Schmidt, wie groß sind Sie und wie viel liegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin 1,70 Meter groß und wiege aktuell 72 Kilogramm.
Okay, Herr Schmidt, was wird Sie zu uns heute? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich komme zu Ihnen, weil ich schon seit mehreren Wochen Schmerzen im Oberbauch habe.
Wo genau die Schmerzen?
Im Oberbauch, mittig.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen? Sie haben gesagt mehrere Wochen, aber?
Ja, seit mehreren Wochen.
Okay. Wo genau, wie kann Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben? Eher dumpf oder krampfartig oder sicher?
Das sind ja dumpfe brennende Schmerzen.
Brennende, okay.
Dumpfe brennende.
Traten Sie die Schmerzen in anderen Körperteilen aus?
Nein.
Haben Sie bestimmte Auslöse bemerkt?
Ja, immer nach dem Essen habe ich das Problem.
Nach dem Essen. Nach dem bestimmten Essen oder allgemein?
Allgemein.
Und haben Sie, gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer neuen Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leichte Schmerzen und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen bedeutet?
Ja, ungefähr so 5, 6.
5 bis 6.
Sie haben gesagt, nach dem Essen die Schmerzen verschlimmen. Jetzt 5 oder 6 oder immer?
Ja, jetzt habe ich aktuell wenig Schmerzen, weil ich seit gestern Nacht nichts mehr gegessen habe.
Aktuell wenig Schmerzen, okay.
Herr Schmidt, außer den Schmerzen leiden Sie unter anderem Beschwerden?
Übelkeit.
Ich habe manchmal noch Übelkeit, ja.
Müssen Sie schon erbrechen?
Erbrochen habe ich noch nicht, nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Leiden Sie unter Schütterfrost, Nachtschweiß, Karchweiß?
Nein.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Schmidt?
Ja, ich habe eigentlich guten Appetit, aber ich esse ein bisschen weniger in der letzten Zeit.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie Gewichtveränderungen bemerkt?
Ich habe etwas abgenommen, ja. Ich habe ungefähr 3 Kühle abgenommen.
Innerhalb welcher Zeitraum haben Sie?
Also 3 Wochen ungefähr.
Schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Schlafprobleme, Herr Schmidt?
Ich schlafe eigentlich ganz gut, ja.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten oder eher plötzlich aufgetreten?
Also langsam.
Langsam.
Wie verändert die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit? Verschlimmer oder?
Schlimmer geworden, ja.
Deswegen diese Schmerzen? Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein oder waren Sie Hausarzt?
Ich war noch nicht beim Hausarzt. Ich habe Ibuprofen eingewiesen.
Ibuprofen. Wissen Sie die Dosierung?
600 Milligramm.
600. Sind die Ibuprofen mit Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlasten?
Nein.
Oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie Farbeveränderungen im Rind oder Stuhl?
Nein.
Bemerkt?
Sie haben gesagt, dunfe und brennende Schmerzen.
Ja.
Bleiben Sie unter Saltbrennen oder Ausstoßen?
Nicht als Schlüssel.
Okay.
Bleiben Sie unter Husten oder Herzrasen?
Bleiben Sie unter Atemnot oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie chronische Erkrankungen haben?
Bitte?
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdur?
Ja, ich habe einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
In welchem Bereich Bandscheibenvorfall?
In der Lendenwirbelsäule.
Lenden.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Schon seit fünf Jahren jetzt.
Okay.
Wie behandelt diese Krankheit?
Also ich nehme immer Ibuprofen ein und Physiotherapie.
Manchmal macht der Orthopäde auch Spritzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Ich habe wenig Cholesterinerhöhung, aber der Haushalt meint, das wäre noch im Rahmen.
Herr Schmidt, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Ich wurde am Knie operiert vor 20 Jahren ungefähr an einem Lineskos-Problem.
Ist das Arthroskopie oder offene Operation?
Das wurde nicht aufgeschnitten.
Das war mit so einer Kamera und so haben wir das gemacht.
Okay.
Noch etwas Operationen?
Nein.
Gut.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig außer Ibuprofen irgendeine andere Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Sie nehmen immer 600 mg Ibuprofen oder?
Genau.
Wie häufig nehmen Sie täglich?
Ein bis zwei Mal am Tag.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, brauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke Alkohol, ja.
Wie viel trinken Sie und seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich habe schon immer Alkohol getrunken.
Seit meiner Jugend trinke ich schon Alkohol, aber ich trinke nicht viel.
Ich trinke vielleicht vier, fünf Flaschen in der Woche Bier.
Vier, fünf Flaschen Bier?
Nach dem Feierabend in der Woche.
Okay.
Denken Sie bitte nicht persönlich, aber das ist eine rote Frage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Schmidt?
Bitte?
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nicht das ich wüsste, nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Leider nicht.
Ich vermute das wegen dieser Knieprobleme, oder?
Ich glaube eher Faulheit.
Herr Schmidt, in Ihrer Familie, besonders Vater, Mutter oder Geschwister,
haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Also mein Vater und meine Mutter leben nicht mehr.
Sie sind beide verstorben.
Oh, es tut mir leid.
Ja, die waren schon alt.
Mein Bruder hatte einen Herzinfarkt jetzt vor drei Jahren.
Meine Schwester hat eigentlich keine Erkrankungen.
Wissen Sie, woran Ihre Eltern gestorben sind?
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Meine Mutter hatte Brustkrebs.
Brustkrebs.
Herr Schmidt, sind Sie verheiratet und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder und eine Frau.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin Elektriker.
Elektriker.
Haben Sie Schadresse bei der Arbeit?
Wie immer, normal.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, Sie haben seit ein paar Wochen Überbruchschmerzen.
Diese Schmerzen sind dunkel und brennend und mit keinem Ausstrahlen.
Und Sie haben gesagt, nach dem Essen, diese Schmerzen verschieben.
Sie haben dagegen immer vorfahren eingenommen.
Herr Schmidt, ich habe mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen Sie an mich?
Nein.
Vielen Dank für dieses Analysegespräch.
Herr Schmidt, bitte warten Sie hier und legen Sie auf die Liege.
Ich komme zurück für Sie körperliche Untersuchungen.
Vielen Dank.
Bis gleich.
War viel freigestimmt. Bitte schön.
Herr Schmidt, leiden Sie unter Schluchstörungen?
Nein.
Und nehmen Sie Ibuprofen mit nuchteren Magen oder Vollmagen?
Mit was?
Nehmen Sie Ibuprofen mit nuchteren Magen oder Vollmagen?
Das ist unterschiedlich. So wie Schmerzen haben.
Und keine Magen-Säure haben?
Nein.
Danke.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Was essen Sie normalerweise täglich?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Wie sind Ihre Essgehornheiten?
Gut.
Aber was essen Sie?
Wie meinen Sie, was esse ich?
Zum Beispiel Fleisch.
Ja, esse ich. Ich esse alles.
Herr Schmidt, leiden Sie auch die Unterblähungen?
Manchmal, aber nicht immer.
Danke.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Wie viele Kissen brauchen Sie beim Schlafen?
Ein Kiss.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder treten Sie nur nach dem Essen auf?
Hauptsächlich nach dem Essen.
Wie lange dauern die Schmerzen?
Ja, schon so 2-3 Stunden meistens.
Nennen Sie sie scharfig?
Normal.
Danke.
Trinken Sie viel Kaffee?
Ja.
Wie viel?
Viel.
Zum Beispiel täglich?
Wie viele Tassen?
4-5 Tassen am Tag schon.
Okay.
Dann fangen wir an.
Ja.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und möchte Ihnen diesen Falkurs vorstellen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, darf ich?
Ja klar, gerne.
Es geht um Herr Paul Schmidt, der 58-jährige Patientin.
Er ist 1,70 Meter groß und 2,72 Kilogramm schwer aktuell.
Der Patient täte sich heute bei uns wegen seit ein paar Wochen bestehender,
progredienter, langsam aufgetretener und besonders postbrandierer
verschiedenen Mörder epigastrischer Schmerzen vor.
Der Schmerzintest liegt bei 5 plus 6 von 10 auf einer Nummereschertskala.
Die Schmerzen sind im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Deswegen nimmt er Ibuprofen ein.
Diese Medikamente haben sich weniger erinnern gebracht.
Außerdem leidet er unter Nausea, aber musste er nicht Emesis.
Die Fragen nach Pirosis, Ruckthus, Vertigo, Fieber,
Nachtschweiß, Kaltschweiß und Tussis und Tachycardie würden verneint.
Er hat keinen Brutschmerzen.
Die Vegetative-Anamnese bis auf 2 Kilogramm innerhalb von 2 Wochen
Gebietverlust unauffällig.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit 5 Jahren an Discosprolapsus
im Lendenwirbelsäulebereich.
Außerdem hat er erhochte Cholesterinwerte, aber es behandelt sich nicht mit Medikamenten.
An Voroperationen würde bei ihm im Alter von 20 Jahren
eine arthroskopische Menuskosoperation durchgeführt.
In der Medikament-Tesis-Anamnese berichtete er, dass er regelmäßig
Ibuprofen 600 mg ein- oder zweimal täglich ein.
Allergien und Unfalltäglichkeiten würden verneint.
Der Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Er treibt nicht regelmäßig Sport.
In der Noxon-Anamnese berichtete er, dass er nicht rauchen.
Er trinkt seit Jugendlichen 4-5 Flaschen Bier jede Woche.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Besonders in der Familienanamnese sind beide Eltern gestorben.
Sein Vater hatte Apoplex gelitten und seine Mutter hatte Mammakarcinom gelitten.
Er hat einen Bruder.
Der Bruder hat einen Myokardinfarkt vor 3 Jahren gelitten.
Seine Schwester ist gesund.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei Kinder und lebt mit ihren Familien zusammen.
Er ist Elektriker vom Beruf.
Er hat Schätze bei der Arbeit, aber nicht so schlimm.
Er hat Oberarzt.
Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine Ulkoskanzlekule hin.
Differenzierte Diagnostik kommen Gastritis, Ulkosklinik oder Magenkarsenom in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen oder Differenzierte Diagnose auszuschließen,
werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen, danach Blut vor Labor abnehmen und eine Abdomen-Sonographie durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich auf Peritonitis, Abverspannung, Loslassschmerzen,
Druckschmerzen, Hautfarbeveränderungen und Anämiescheiben.
Dann werde ich Blut vor Labor abnehmen.
Dabei werde ich Blutbild, Hämatoprotein, Hemoglobin, Cholesterin, Leber und Nieren bestimmen lassen.
Dann gebebenenfalls werde ich Oesophagos Gastrodiagnoskopie durchführen, um die Psychodiagnose zu bestätigen.
Und ja auch Gewebeprobe und Magensäureprobe entnehmen.
Also darum gegebenenfalls, sondern werde ich durchführen.
Ja, genau.
Dann werde ich Oesophagos Gastrodiagnoskopie durchführen, um die Therapie sicher zu bestellen.
Bei der Oesophagos Gastrodiagnoskopie werde ich auch Biopsie oder Magensäure einnehmen, um die Hylkopakterpylori festzustellen.
Und dann Ursachetherapien.
Ja.
Genau. Und was wäre Ihre Therapie?
Ja, als therapeutischer Maßnahmen werde ich den Patienten zunächst stationär aufnehmen.
Wenn wir einen Zugang legen, Flüssigkeit zuführen und Protonen, Pumpe, Hämatoprosol, 45 mg verabreichen.
Und ja, symptomatische Therapie einleiten.
Und dann eine Analystikung, aber keine steroidale Analystikung, sondern Paracetamol oder Methamisol.
Ja. Und nach der Akutbehandlung empfehle ich den Patienten Alkoholkehrens, gesunde Ernährung, Schätzes resultieren.
Was machen Sie denn, wenn die Proben positiv sind, die Sie bei der Magenspiegelung abnehmen?
Ja, wenn die Hylkopakterpylori vorhanden ist, werde ich Triple Therapie einleiten.
Protonen Pumpe, Hämatoprosol und Klaestromosin oder andere verschiedene Triple Therapie Methoden getestet.
Wissen Sie, welche momentan die empfohlenen Therapien sind, hier in Deutschland?
Momentan, ich bin nicht sicher, aber die französischen und italienischen Therapie Methoden, ja, glaube ich.
Die werden beide nicht mehr gemacht. Die werden beide nicht mehr gemacht. Sondern es gibt jetzt die Triple Therapie.
Ja, mit Bismuth eine Therapie gibt. Ich bin jetzt die Herr ganz genau. Ich werde gastroenterologische Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Genau, ganz gut. Sehr gut. Was empfehlen Sie nochmal dem Patienten wegen der oder was denken Sie, warum hat er diese Ulkosventrucholie?
Ja, er trinkt Alkohol. Außerdem nimmt er seit fünf Jahren regelmäßig nichtstoraidelle Antiromatika in die Pupulofen.
Deswegen denke ich, diese nichtstoraidelle Antiromatika ist die Ursache von Ulkosventrucholie.
Ja, ganz genau. Was würden Sie als Alternative zu dieser nichtstoraidelle Antiromatikatherapie empfehlen?
Alternative Therapie ist Stereodaltherapie, aber es ist auch gefährlich mit Magen.
Ich empfehle Ihnen nichtstoraidelle Antiromatika mit Magenschutz oder mit Magenschutz.
Oder Sie können auch alternative Medikamente anordnen.
Statt NSAR können Sie auch überlegen, ob man auch Novo-Minsulfon zum Beispiel umswitcht.
Mit Amizol kann man vielleicht probieren.
Man sollte natürlich auch dann mit dem Orthopäden Rücksprache halten oder der Patient sollte Rücksprache halten,
damit eine Alternative Therapie für die Bandscheiben und Schmerzen weitergefüllt werden kann.
Er muss arbeiten, er hat Schmerzen, er muss irgendeine Schmerzmedikation erhalten.
Wichtig ist, wie Sie gesagt haben, die PPI-Therapie mit Pratoprazol oder Omeprazol.
Denn keine andere Möglichkeit besteht außer einer NSAR-Therapie.
Ja, genau.
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank Herr Oberarzt.
Ich frag Ihnen. Gut gemacht. Super. Alles super. Gibt es Fragen? Einfacher Fall gewesen.
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Man kommt sehr oft vor in der Aufnahme, Notaufnahme, oft auch mit Teerstuhl zusammen.
Ja.
Viele haben Teerstuhl und da muss man auch an eine Blutung nachdenken, an einen Magen.
Ja, ich habe gefragt, ob Sie ein Stück bei der Veränderung haben.
Ja, alles richtig gemacht.
Ich habe morgen eine Prüfung in Stuttgart.
Ich drücke in die Daumen. Ich hoffe, das wird gut.
Vielen Dank.